hey everybody how's it going it's uh
we're guests are about a good chunk of
the way through i/o so it's I have time
to talk about security so I have a
security question for you oh you do and
you type your password please I I can
you should never do this thank you
kindly the demo effect it is already
upon us before we've even started so
we're gonna be talking about securing
your apps and user data with Google
cloud just like the title says and it is
i/o so I get to talk about my favorite
part of i/o which is all of the really
cool applications that all of you are
building so my favorite part is kind of
meandering around through the crowd and
talking about the challenges and
excitement that you're all encountering
some people are writing applications
about travel or finance other people are
writing applications about staying safe
on bicycles and it's this variation and
software that makes all of our apps
special it's kind of the reason we write
them anyway and this means that it is
very difficult for us to give you an
overall talk about security that is
perfectly fit for all of your needs
because just like your applications have
things that are special about them the
security needs you have are also going
to be oftens very specific to the
solutions you're working on and the
technology used to implement them but we
need to talk about something so we are
going to talk about security on an
application that we have developed and
hopes that you can apply some of this
information to the applications that you
work on that application is add a cat to
that the way this application works is
you take an awesome photo like this
photo I took in San Francisco a couple
weeks ago I think it's pretty nice
already The Painted Ladies Sunita
landmark could we make it better we
might be able to make it better because
that is the next step you take that
photo you send it out to the cloud and
in the cloud we
do sophisticated artificial intelligence
and send that photo back to you improved
because everyone knows that the internet
benefits from more cats so we make it
even better oh yes we can make it even
better because it does support recursive
submission of the photos the photo that
comes out you can send it back to add a
cat to that and add as many cats as you
want by submitting it over and over
again and then once it's ready once
you've reached sufficient cat load you
can upload it to your favorite photo
sharing site and you are good to go and
properly paying homage to the true
nature of the Internet so let's take a
quick look at our application in action
so if we could go to the demo oh do you
want to switch to the web browser sure
we're revealing the code oh here it is
here's add a cat to that in our
wonderful mobile first interface we're
going to submit one of my favorite
pictures of cake because food photos are
the other half of the Internet we'll add
a caption so that everyone knows what we
think of the photo and their photo is
improved yay but this is a developer
conference you're not here just to see
our interface so let's take a look at
the code and see how we've implemented
this here is the truth about add a cat
to that we're not doing any
sophisticated machine learning yet
because this is our MVP or Minimum
Viable Product just enough to go out and
try and raise some money it's actually a
very short Python program about 20 lines
of code implemented using a micro
framework called flask it all really
does is the photo gets posted up and
then we fork off a sub process to a
common image manipulation program called
image magic take the results and send it
back to our users and this is this is
pretty easy to get together then we had
to think about how we're going to run
the software this is a Greenfield
application like we're starting from
scratch so be the opportunity to take
advantage of a lot of the new cool
development techniques and that's where
docker came in so that we can enable
fast development environment creation
and easy deployment
Chinn we package it all up in a docker
file which was a snap we went to docker
got the helloworld tutorial and just
changed it so that the bytes the Python
3.7 base image is now uploading are now
combining all the files for our
application and then running it in
unicorn a flask runner cool so with that
let's go oh wait one more thing we want
to look at see how we're running it in
production yep
so we're gonna go on over to the console
since we are also using a docker
container not only did we get the
benefits of a really easy development
environment to kick up but we also have
a whole bunch of places that we can
almost click a button and run it in
production and at the current stage of
addict after that we are using the beta
cloud run which we've made available a
few weeks back and it's a really great
fit for us we uploaded the image use
cloud build and it was pretty much
turnkey apply a pointer or domain name
at it we were ready to start pitching
our application for the next round of
funding but this is when the next
question came up which if we can go back
to the slides this is when the question
of security finally started to come on
we're going around we're talking to
potential investors and we're getting
this question over and over again
everyone wants to know if our
application is secure is it secure
that's a little more complicated I guess
we'll be getting into that with most of
the session over and over again we heard
horror stories of people's previous
investments ending up in the headlines
but the truth is Security's not really a
binary thing it's not a yes or no
question
you don't just flip a switch and
suddenly your application is secure it's
much more complex than that
a little fuzzy maybe even like a kind of
a gradient is another way of thinking
about it to work towards a more secure
application to move further along that
spectrum we need to do some work we need
to put on our attacker hat and do an
exercise called threat modeling in
threat modeling what you do
you take advantage of the fact that you
are probably the best person to attack
your software since you know everything
about it or most of the things and then
you use what you learn from that process
to make your application safer one of
the kind of the foundations of this
technique is that a hacker is probably
not just going to randomly hack at your
software well they might but probably
not they're probably after something
specific they probably have a goal in
mind this might be your user data this
might be financial information that you
have in a database or the truth is the
goal could actually be outside your
organization they might be using you as
a stepping stone to get at something
else like they might want to take
advantage of an open-source library you
maintain that other people use but they
won't be able to get straighted that
goal because it's important to you it's
probably pretty well protected so an
attacker is going to look for
intermediate resources they're going to
investigate your environment and try and
find different things that they can take
advantage of to pivot and move around
and make it further into your system
these intermediate resources could be
things like servers running in a cluster
but they can also be things like
libraries you depend on or even your
developers themselves and as they
investigate they're also going to try
and learn about any defensive measures
you have in place
anything from password policies to
auditing you do to firewall rules and
the like they're probably going to start
the process of enumerate all these
things from information they can
publicly find online like photos from
your last company party that made it up
to LinkedIn somehow and maybe look at a
foothold in at some point and they'll
spend time very carefully and gradually
enumerated all those intermediate
resources and all those defensive
measures you have in place until they
find a way to string them all together
to wiggle around the defensive measures
you have in place and strike at that
goal and get access to that information
or plant that malware or whatever they
want to do and this is called a kill
chain this part can happen very quickly
but what we want to do is we want to
defend against those threats and our
first impulse might be after doing some
threat modeling and figuring out a kill
chain that someone might be able to do
would be to take one of our defensive
measures and just beef it up more
firewall rules more broken down network
that kind of stuff but that's not always
the best investment of your time going
straight to our pet solutions is not
always the best thing we can do it turns
out that often a better use of your time
is to focus on removing unnecessary
things that could potentially be
intermediate resources and of the ones
that you need to keep reducing the
attack surface to make them smaller and
in addition to that rather than have one
strong defensive measure in place in a
certain area it's more effective to have
a greater number of easier to maintain
defensive measures that overlap so that
if one fails another one might get
triggered and this technique is called
defense-in-depth so that if one thing
fails for whatever reason you have
another backup behind it to help protect
you and this is the philosophy that we
we believe in very strongly at Google so
we all have multiple different things we
want to protect today we're going to be
talking about a few different things
that you can do to establish that
defense-in-depth we're gonna be talking
about secure supply chain which is about
making sure you don't deploy bad code
that someone else wrote wrote or deploy
dependencies that might have problems
that we already know about we're gonna
talk about automatic vulnerability
scanning so that we can find that
low-hanging fruit those silly mistakes
we make that we kick ourselves when we
find before someone else finds them for
us and we're gonna talk about the the
nut behind the wheel another potential
weakness making sure that phishing does
not cause us a problem because phishing
is something that we often joke about
and we tease people but it's a surprise
easily effective technique in offensive
security despite the fact that you know
we were all immune to phishing obviously
surprisingly not so first let's think in
one of those deeper let's talk about
secure supply chain in the context of
attic add to that so attic add to that
is a very short program like you saw it
has like a dozen lines of code that's
kind of the core functionality but
believe it or not has hundreds of
dependencies and this is one of the
things that made it so easy to write add
a cat to that is we all kind of stand on
the shoulders of giants we get to
include a lot of other people's work to
get started very quickly and make very
rapid progress as developers but some of
those things we depend on might be
neglected or someone else might have
made a mistake so that's a really large
surface for her things to potentially go
wrong and we don't want to be sad and in
fact begins we had to get an idea of how
big this risk is in 2018
there were over 16,000 published
vulnerabilities called CVS and
invulnerability databases and that's way
too many to like keep track of manually
so if we try to like subscribe to
newsletters and then kind of investigate
a toccata that each time to see if we're
impacted like we're never gonna be able
to keep up but we're software developers
and we encounter a problem like that we
solve it with software and fortunately
we are using Google will contain a
registry to store our container images
before we push them to reduction in
cloud run and I'd like to show you a
feature of that that can help us keep
our supply chain secure so with that
let's go back to the demo so here is the
container registry where all of the
Attic after that images are published
and if we go over to the settings pane
of container registry we will see a
feature that is normally off by default
it is a beta feature but it is awesome
it is worth checking even if you're a
little bit beta skittish
we've already enabled it ahead of time
it's called vulnerability scanning and
now if we go back to our list of images
and go into our web application image
you will see a new column has appeared
on the far side and if we click into
that we will see that our image which
only has like a few dependencies or so
we thought and like a dozen lines of
actual code has over 600 vulnerabilities
and only 38 fixes like that's like six
or seven percent that even can be fixed
so is at this point that a lot of people
might start to panic but don't panic
it's okay it's better that we know about
these early on right how are we gonna
solve 600 vulnerabilities well first
let's investigate if any of them are
actually relevant to us because these
vulnerabilities are related to the
dependencies we use but they might not
actually impact the way we use our
application so let's click in on one of
the image magic ones because that's one
of the things we use and here you'll
find details on exactly what it is like
this one is an uninitialized variable
leading to memory corruption so if we
wanted to we could dig through the
potential use cases we could do a threat
modeling we could do through all the use
cases that I can't do that does and see
if this is even relevant to us and even
if there's not a fix we might be able to
set up we have gonna do defense-in-depth
instead of a secondary measure that
protects us from this particular issue
although this one looks kind of bad so
let's see if we can come up with a
different way to mitigate this issue so
for that let's look at an experiment
Rance if we go back to the code we did
an experiment well first of all when we
looked at all of our potential
vulnerabilities we notice that a whole
bunch of them are related to image magic
image magic is wonderful it is super
fast but it is also very complicated and
has has a lot of vulnerabilities that
get discovered in it as a result so we
discover that there is a pure Python
implementation we can do to implement
the exact same functionality it's a
Python library called pillow and with
there's a few lines of code change we
were able to re-implement add a cat to
that and remove the forked image magic
process from it which is a huge win
another thing we did was we tweaked our
docker file a little bit
as much as the hello world Python 3.7
image got to started fast it turns out
it had a whole bunch of stuff in it that
we didn't need at all which were well
represented in that vulnerability list
so we went and grabbed a slimmed-down
base image and there's a lot of these
available
we chose alpine linux for this one and
we had to do a little more work here we
had to explicitly install all of our
real dependencies but other than that
the docker file is pretty much the same
but that one little change Boop we shot
it back up to container registry and
stuck it in the experimental and you
will notice that if we go over to the
vulnerabilities tab oh it's it right
there - it shows up in the interface a
few places surprisingly I thought there
would still be some vulnerabilities but
it got it all the way back down to zero
with just a tiny little change and the
truth is that this change did have a
cost it is slower and it uses more
memory now but that is the decision that
we have to make we have to decide if the
performance overhead is worth it to this
or if we want to put in other maybe more
complicated or time you know time more
difficult interventions in place to
prevent it
in this case least for us were at the
MVP stage we just want to show some cool
demos and not get pwned in the process
this is a great solution for us so with
that like I guess we're probably ready
to go I think we're done yeah I don't
know why don't you uh tell us a little
bit more let's go back to the slide so I
think everything's secure now right
because we've fixed all of the
dependency chain and we just eliminated
600 vulnerabilities in a matter of
minutes but those two changes and we
review all our code every night
especially two in the morning usually at
2:00 to 3:00 in the morning the night
before the demo yeah after so maybe
we've made some mistakes maybe you all
have made some mistakes and your code is
not 100% perfect because we we all
introduced some bugs well I also want to
tell you about a tool that can help you
there so Google's web security scanner
will do automated testing of your
deployed code to find those bugs that
you've introduced vulnerabilities
unintentionally and rather than tell you
all about it let's just show you let's
switch to the laptop sure so we're gonna
bring up cloud security scanner
once we switch to our demo and what you
can see here is the simple of you I'm in
GCP let's make a new scan just to walk
through the steps it's very very fast so
as we make a new scan we're gonna point
this at a staging URL for our app
because this is actually gonna be fuzz
testing our web app and you don't want
to put that at point that at your
production instance so you're gonna be
introducing a whole lot of wacky data
and it might corrupt your your
application so pointed at something in
staging your dev we've put in the
committee's pod address there the rest
of these things you can leave is default
I would head down and make this run
daily so it can automatically update you
when any new issues are found because of
a new push so we're gonna say this it's
gonna take about 15 minutes or so to
actually get going so let me show you
one cat scan that we made earlier just
you can see what some of that output
looks like our code is totally safe
right right there's some issues it looks
like scanner found stuff all right let's
see what the cross-site scripting issues
are okay
those can be scary yeah so the web
security scanner starts crawling around
all the URLs that can find and starts
looking for these known vulnerabilities
in this case it found a cross-site
scripting bug in our admin login page
and what is giving us right here is the
exact way to replicate that bug so the
we can troubleshoot and then fix it so
we're gonna make sure let's take a look
at the test data gave us so we can
reproduce it I'm gonna drop it into a
new file so we're gonna show you this
bug live and then we're gonna fix it
right now so that we can knock yet
another vulnerability off of a tack app
to that we don't want our cats to be
insecure so taking that HTML from web
security scanner we can see here that
that doesn't look right
no it should say the email address of
the person who tried to login not some
weird stuff yeah that's that's pretty
weird let's go to the login page HTML
and see if we can fix this okay it's
right here so this login page which is
called out by the web security scanner
this is where that HTML came from and
yeah that's I remember now what happened
back when we were writing this the first
time we assumed anything submitted to
this form was gonna be totally safe as
it was gonna be just coming from in
right because we wanted people to have
email addresses with pictures yeah now
that we're getting ready to launch maybe
we should reconsider that well it's an
easy fix
let's take that out remove that all
right now we're allowing the cross side
scripting prevention that we had
actually disabled before I'm sorry for
the double negative so we pushed that
fixed build to production right now and
the coolest part about this whole
process and the tool is that the web
security scanner doesn't cost you
anything to use this is free it's very
easy it's not perfect neither is your
code but it's gonna catch a lot of those
common easy to prevent errors it's not
gonna protect you from a sophisticated
attack or a new clever zero-day but it
will help you with things that may have
slipped past your code of view process
very low friction and it's
fire-and-forget once you set up that
daily scan it's gonna keep going all
right let's go back to the slides so we
have secured our dependency chain by
fixing some of those library issues
we've made sure our code is secure now
we're safe right there's no possible way
someone could compromise out of cat to
that well what if somebody manages to
get into my account or Jen's account
with a good phishing attack all of those
previous protections are useless so I
want to talk about the people and how
you can secure the people with better
authentication a typical login flow
looks something like this you present
your login and password to the server
and then you're in Oh No somebody was
actually giving you a very clever
phishing page you've given them your
credentials and now they're logging in
and doing anything that you could have
done they can modify your source code
they could add some malware
I think it's sign of malicious binary
with your keys this is terrible there's
a lot about things but you think I'm
good I have this one time password that
my phone gives me it doesn't always work
though man
so the Fisher can just take that one
time password two and now they're
passing it forward and they're logging
in if you just this successfully this
doesn't actually prevent phishing so I
want to tell you about a better way
these security keys which you can either
get as USB key or Bluetooth and now you
can actually use your Android phone
thanks to announcement a few weeks ago
from google these will do a much
stronger second factor to make your
logins secure so I'm gonna replay that
previous scenario in a way that's gonna
stop fishing in its tracks instead of
being complete after you give vlog a
name and password the server replies
with a challenge it knows that you
registered a security key on to your
account already and it has the public
encryption key for that security game so
you get that challenge back and your
security key when you tap it is actually
verifying the domain that it's talking
to that means a phishing domain even a
very cleverly disguised one with a URL
that looks almost exactly the same
except for that weird ASCII character
that's using that's not really an open
looks like an O won't work the key won't
sign that challenge and return if the
domain isn't exactly what it was set up
with the domain checks out your security
key signs it returns a challenge now the
server can validate that you use the key
that it expected that you already
registered in the past so it knows that
you not only possess your password but
you also possess that key something you
know something you have now you've
authenticated in a way that's extremely
resistant to phishing we've been using
this a lot at Google and it's really
effective let's switch to the demo I'm
going to show you how it works
so Jen why do you login okay here's your
account put in the password and now it's
gonna ask for one more step security key
plug that in give it a tap alright we
are in now Jen's a super admin on this
domain we definitely want to protect
those accounts it's really really
important so I would recommend that you
security keys for everyone that's not
practical in all circumstances so let's
say you want to set it up just for your
engineering team let's go into the
security settings in our Google admin
we're gonna go look at our basic
settings and get into the advanced
two-factor 2-step security settings from
here we can choose what kind of
enforcement let's turn on to factor for
end of May but actually we also want to
make sure that we're doing this for
people were really matter so we can set
it up just for the engineering group
right we can probably get them keys and
time behold two-person engineering team
exactly perfect
so we can select the engineering team
right here and now we can say turn on
enforcement for the anime and you can
decide what kinds of two-step
authentication
you're gonna allow I think we only want
security keys because as we just learned
an OTP is just as fishable as the
password as soon as we save this we're
set it's as easy as that all right let's
go back to the slides so we've had you
here for a little while we've been
working on out of cat 2 that what do you
think have we made it more secure yeah
are we done
no well let's review what we have done
we've secured our supply chain with the
Google container registry and scan to
find some dependencies that we needed to
remove we have looked at our own code
and our web app to find some cross-site
scripting vulnerabilities that we could
also fix and we've added stronger
authentication for engineering team so
it's much harder for someone malicious
to take over one of our accounts but
you're not all making out a cat to that
at least I hope not because you are I
have I have a lawyer who needs to talk
to you your software is different than
ours and that means the threats you face
are gonna be different than what we're
looking at and what's important to you
might not be as important to us you need
to have your own security strategy so
this is the beginning and I hope that
you'll explore some of the security
features google cloud or the other
platforms that you're using and I hope
that you'll do a little bit of
exploration of the documentation I also
want you to do some threat modeling put
on that attacker hat figure out what
someone who knows a lot about your
application could do if they were
feeling especially nasty this is the
start of your journey but it's just the
beginning thank you very much for
joining us
[Music]